DANA PERINO, ALONG WITH
JESSE WATTERS, GREG GUTFELD,
JUAN WILLIAMS, AND
KATIE PAVLICH.
IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS THE FIVE.
♪ ♪
>> WE CAN BEGIN THE NEXT FRONT
IN OUR WAR, WHICH WE ARE CALLING
OPENING UP AMERICA AGAIN.
WE MUST HAVE A WORKING ECONOMY.
AND WE WANT TO GET IT BACK VERY,
VERY QUICKLY.
AND THAT’S WHAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
I BELIEVE IT WILL BLOOM.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, THAT WAS
THE REAL EVENT.
OBVIOUSLY, HE WAS PREPARING THE
NATION FOR THE NEXT FRONT IN
THIS WAR AGAINST COVID-19.
AS THE WHITE HOUSE RELEASES OR
GUIDELINES FOR SAFE REOPENING
CAREFULLY, AND IN THREE SEPARATE
PHASES.
THE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE WILL
COME AGAIN IN AN HOUR FROM NOW
FOR THE FRIDAY UPDATE.
SO IN THE MEANTIME WE WILL BREAK
IT ALL DOWN.
FIRST OF ALL, THE FIRST PHASE TO
SEE THE REOPENING OF GYMS,
RESTAURANTS, MAY BE THEATERS,
AND SPORTS VENUES, BUT WITH
STRICT SOCIAL DISTANCING
MEASURES IN PLACE.
SCHOOLS WOULD STAY CLOSED, AND
HIGH-RISK INDIVIDUALS WOULD STAY
HOME.
TO THE OTHER PHASES WOULD THEN
LOOSEN RESTRICTIONS MORE IF
CASES CONTINUE TO FALL.
BUT THERE ARE SOME CRITICS THAT
THAT -- OF THE PLAN INCLUDING
NANCY PELOSI, CALLING THEM VAGUE
AND INCONSISTENT.
HERE IS MORE REACTION FROM OTHER
DEMOCRATS.
>> I THINK WHAT HE HAS KIND OF
DONE IS PUNTED COMING HE HAS
DECIDED THAT HE DOES NOT HAVE
THE RIGHT TO MAKE THE CALL FOR
THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHO HAS A
ILLNESS, WHO IS IMMUNE TO THE
ILLNESS AND WHO CAN GET THE
ILLNESS BEFORE WE CAN DETERMINE
WHO CAN GO BACK TO WORK.
>> OKAY, IT IS UP TO THE STATES,
BUT THEN DON’T ASK THE STATES,
DON’T GIVE THEM A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE AND THEN NOT GIVE
THEM ANY RESOURCES TO DO IT.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, HAPPY
FRIDAY.
GREG, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF
PERSPECTIVE TO SET THIS UP,
BECAUSE IN A WAY ALL OF US FEEL
LIKE IT IS GROUNDHOG’S DAY.
IT HAS BEEN ABOUT FOUR WEEKS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THE
SHOW REMOTELY FROM HERE.
AND LAST FRIDAY WAS THE END OF
THE WEEK IN WHICH JEROME ADAMS,
THE SURGEON GENERAL HAS SAID
THAT THIS WILL BE OUR
PEARL HARBOR MOMENT, HOPEFULLY
REACHING THE APEX AND THE PEAK.
THIS WEEK WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE REOPENING.
AND WE HAVE SOME GUIDANCE.
SOME OF IT IS VAGUE BECAUSE THE
STATES ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
DECIDE BASED ON THEIR DIFFERENT
CRITERIA.
ISN’T THAT A LITTLE BIT OF A
HOPEFUL SIGN THAT IT’S NOT JUST
ONE BIG BLOCK AND WE CAN LOOK AT
SOME PROGRESS?
>> Greg: I DON’T SEE ANYTHING
HERE THAT IS VAGUE.
I SEE A ROAD MAP AND YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO DRIVE IT.
WHAT DRIVES ME CRAZY IS THAT IF
TRUMP HAD TAKEN MORE COMMAND
OVER THIS.
INSTEAD, THIS IS WHAT YOU’RE
GOING TO DO, THEY WOULD’VE
ACCUSED HIM OF BEING A DICTATOR
AND A TYRANT.
IF SO WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE SHARES THE RESPONSIBILITY
WITH THE GOVERNORS.
HERE IS THE ROAD MAP, YOU DRIVE
THE CAR.
AND NOW HE IS ACCUSED OF PUNTING
BY JOE BIDEN?
AND THEN I PREDICTED THIS
YESTERDAY, I SAID THAT
NANCY PELOSI WAS NOT GOING TO
SAY ANYTHING UNTIL AFTER THE
PLAN IS REVEALED BECAUSE SHE DID
NOT WANT ANY SKIN IN THE GAME.
SHE PREFERRED TO STAND IN FRONT
OF HER DOUBLE WIDE REFRIGERATOR
AND SUCK DOWN ICE CREAM UNTIL
SHE GETS AN ICE CREAM HEADACHE
THAN ACTUALLY OFFER PRACTICAL
ADVICE.
YOU CAN SIT ON A BENCH AND YOU
CAN CRAP ON PEOPLE DOING THE JOB
WHEN YOU ARE OUT OF POWER, THAT
MAKE SENSE.
BUT IT IS SO OBVIOUS AND SAD.
IN THE SITUATION, PEOPLE’S LIVES
ARE GOING TO, THERE IS GOING TO
BE DEATH.
EVERY PATH THAT WE CHOOSE IS
GOING TO HAVE DEATH.
SO THE PATH THAT YOU HAVE TO
CHOOSE IS A ROAD MAP IN WHICH
YOU CAN GO IN REVERSE.
OR YOU CAN PAUSE.
OR YOU CAN TAKE A LEFT OR A
RIGHT.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS.
YOU ARE A SPORTS CAR WITH A
STICK SHIFT, AND YOU SHIFT GEARS
BASED ON THE TERRAIN THAT IS
COMING AT YOU.
AND YOU CAN EVEN GO IN REVERSE.
THAT’S WHAT THE GUIDELINE IS.
SO TO SIT THERE AND GO, IT’S
VAGUE AND INCONSISTENT, YOU ARE
JUST AN IDIOT.
PURE AND SIMPLE, STICK TO YOUR
ICE CREAM.
[LAUGHS]
>> Dana: AND I THINK WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF TRUMP TWEETS AND A
GOVERNOR CUOMO SOUND BITE.
IF YOU CAN PULL THOSE UP SO I
CAN READ THOSE.
GOVERNOR CUOMO SHOULD SPEND MORE
TIME DOING AND LESS COMPLAINING.
GET OUT THERE AND GET THE JOB
DONE.
TO STOP TALKING, WE BUILT YOU
THOUSANDS OF HOSPITAL BEDS THAT
YOU DID NOT NEED OR USE, GAVE
LARGE NUMBERS OF VENTILATORS
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE HAD AND
HELPED YOU WITH.
THERE’S A LITTLE BIT MORE,
TESTING THAT YOU SHOULD BE
DOING.
WE HAVE GIVEN NEW YORK FAR MORE
MONEY, HELP, AND EQUIPMENT BUT
IN ANY STATE BY FAR, AND THE MEN
AND WOMEN NEVER HEAR YOU SAY
THANKS.
YOUR NUMBERS ARE NOT GOOD.
LESS TALK AND MORE ACTION.
I THINK IT DOES SAY THANK YOU
ALLOTTED TO THE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, BUT GOVERNOR CUOMO
DECIDED TO RESPOND.
WE HAVE A SOUND BITE OF THAT.
LET’S LISTEN.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IF HE IS
SITTING HOME WATCHING TV, MAYBE
HE SHOULD GET UP AND GO TO WORK,
RIGHT?
SECOND, LET’S KEEP EMOTION AND
POLITICS OUT OF THIS AND
PERSONAL EGO IF WE CAN, BECAUSE
THIS IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
IT IS ABOUT HER JOB.
AND LET’S TRY TO FOCUS ON THAT.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, JUAN, I
WILL LET YOU TAKE A WHACK AT
THIS ONE.
>> Juan: I HATE TO SEE US GET
POLITICAL ABOUT THIS.
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT SOMETIMES
THE PRESIDENT LOVES TO BE
CELEBRATED AND THANKED AND ALL
OF THAT.
OKAY.
SO THEN GOVERNOR CUOMO FIRES
BACK.
I’M NOT SURE IT TAKES AS MUCH
ANYWHERE.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE PLAN, DANA,
TO ME I FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY HAS
CABIN FEVER.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE HIGH-END
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS, BUT WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
WE CAN’T LET EMOTIONS THAT DRIVE
US, AND IMPATIENCE, BECAUSE IF
WE DON’T HAVE TESTING.
IF WE DON’T HAVE CONTACT
TRACING, THEN WE CAN GET
OURSELVES IN A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION WHERE WE PUT OUR
WORKERS, THE PEOPLE GOING BACK
TO WORK AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
RISK, AND WE PUT ALL OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS, THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
COME INTO CONTACT WITH, WORK
WITH, ALSO AT RISK.
THEN WE CAN FIND OURSELVES IN A
WORSE SITUATION.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAY, WE
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW TO DEAL
WITH THAT, AND WE WOULD LIKE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT’S HELP, I
THINK IN TERMS OF SPECIFICS,
WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER WAS TALKING
ABOUT, EVEN WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
GOVERNOR CUOMO IN TERMS OF, IF
YOU LAY OUT A PLAN, GIVE US SOME
OF THE RESOURCES TO MAKE IT
WORK, I THINK THAT’S WHAT PEOPLE
ARE SAYING.
IT DOES NOT NECESSARILY HAVE TO
BE SOMETHING NASTY OR DIVISIVE
OR FINGER-POINTING.
>> Dana: ACTUALLY, KATIE.
THERE WERE LOTS OF DIFFERENT
GOVERNORS ON -- GREG IS
LAUGHING, BUT I WILL KEEP GOING.
LOTS OF DIFFERENT GOVERNORS ON
THE SHOWS TODAY TALKING ABOUT
HOW THEY ARE WORKING IN
COORDINATION WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THEIR OWN ROAD MAP, THE
COLORADO GOVERNOR, AND ALL OF
THE STATES HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
A DIFFERENT SITUATION ON THEIR
HAND.
>> Katie: WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID IT IS UP
TO YOU GUYS, DO WHAT YOU WANT
WITH THIS PLAN, IT’S GOING TO BE
IN PHASES, DIFFERENT PLACES WITH
A LOWER DENSITY POPULATION.
DIFFERENT PLACES WILL HAVE A
DIFFERENT PROCESS GOING THROUGH
THIS.
BUT IT’S INTERESTING WHAT IS
WILL HAPPENING IN D.C. WHERE
LAWMAKERS ARE AT HOME.
YOU HAVE CHUCK SCHUMER AND
NANCY PELOSI CRITICIZING THE
PLAN, AND SAYING THAT YOU HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL AND MAKE SURE THE
ECONOMY IS NOT OPEN TOO QUICKLY.
WHEN THEY ARE SITTING THERE AT
HOME AND NOT REFILLING THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PLAN,
PROGRAM, AND NOT COMING UP WITH
ANY OTHER IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO GET
PEOPLE FROM ECONOMIC HEALTH
WHILE THEY CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE ECONOMY TO BE CLOSE,
IT’S REALLY EASY TO DO THAT.
IT’S ALSO EASY TO DO THAT WHEN
YOU ARE GETTING A PAYCHECK.
IN THE BOTTOM LINE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE GETTING CABIN FEVER IS
THAT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR OWN RISK.
AT THIS POINT THEY UNDERSTAND A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE VIRUS AND WE
DID TWO MONTHS AGO, AND THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT PRECAUTIONS THEY
NEED TO TAKE TO NOT GET SICK,
BUT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT BEING
DICTATED TO BY THE GOVERNMENT.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, JESSE, LET
ME GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD HERE.
>> Jesse: IF DEMOCRATS HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE PLAN, TAKE IT
UP WITH FAUCI AND BIRX.
THEY ARE THE OFFICIALS THAT
SIGNED OFF ON IT.
AND EVERYBODY LOVES
GOVERNOR CUOMO, SO IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP GIVES HIM FREE
POWER AND THEY SAY, HE CAN’T
HANDLE IT OR DO IT BY HIMSELF
ALL OF A SUDDEN, GOVERNOR CUOMO
IS COMPLAINING ABOUT NOT GETTING
THE RESOURCES, HE JUST DONATED
HUNDREDS OF VENTILATORS TO OTHER
STATES BECAUSE HE HAD
OVERCAPACITY.
BECAUSE THE PRESENT AND GAVE SO
MANY.
HE JUST BUILT HOSPITALS DUMB AT
A HOSPITAL IN LONG ISLAND THAT
THEY HAVE NOT EVEN USED TO GET.
I WOULD STOP COMPLAINING ALREADY
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN
YOU ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
THE COUNTRY IS VIEWING THIS FROM
TWO DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE BETTER
OFF, THAT ARE KIND OF HAVING A
LITTLE FUN, MAY BE WORKING FROM
HOME, THEY ARE STILL GETTING
PAID.
THEY ARE ZOOMING, THEY ARE
COOKING.
AND THEN THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
CAN AFFORD TO WORK FROM HOME.
THEY DON’T HAVE A JOB.
THEY HAVE LOST A BUSINESS THAT
HAS BEEN IN THEIR FAMILY FOR
GENERATIONS.
AND TODAY ARE DYING TO GET BACK
TO WORK.
AND ONE SIDE DOES NOT UNDERSTAND
THE OTHER SIDE.
YOU KNOW, HOW COULD YOU NOT WANT
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH?
WHAT ABOUT IF IT SPREADS
FURTHER?
AND THEN THE OTHER SIDE IS
SAYING, WAIT A SECOND, YOU GUYS
UNDERSTAND MY POSITION, I NEED
TO WORK TO FEED MY FAMILY.
OR ELSE, THIS IS IT FOR ME.
AND THEY ARE TALKING ACROSS OF
EACH OTHER, AND A LOT OF IT HAS
TO DO WITH NEW YORK.
THE STATE OF NEW YORK HAS
225,000 CASES.
NEW JERSEY HAS 75,000 CASES.
COMBINED THAT IS 300,000 VIRUS
CASES.
THE NEXT BIGGEST STATE THAT HAS
THAT CASE IS 35,000 IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
OTHER STATES LIKE WYOMING,
NORTH DAKOTA, HAWAII, VERMONT,
WEST VIRGINIA, THEY HAVE A
COUPLE HUNDRED CASES.
AND SO TO SAY THAT TO NEW YORK
SHOULD OPEN UP AT THE SAME RATE
AS VERMONT WHICH HAS LIKE A
HANDFUL OF CASES IS STUPID.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT IS STUPID.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO ATTACK